hey guys I'm Ryan right I'm Adele Wow
confident smooth straight Medel sup
we're gonna watch the trailer today for
a film that I have to win on watch
trailer for a while call Foxcatcher
second trailer do you know anything
about this no and I fur fused to let her
know anything about it I sounds like
it's got something to do with animals
and like someone trying to catch okay
and that's why it's rated R for some
drug use and scene of violence yeah this
is a great assumption yeah all I know is
I think Channing Tatum's in it I think
Steve Carell is also in it but I think
it's a drama or something I'm assuming
is a drama
Veronica stop making noise anyway oh
yeah I don't know anything about it so
adele are you ready to watch this I am
so ready
good good [ __ ] motorcycles can't you
know like you hire a crew stop the
parking and the noise outside and they
can't even get that [ __ ] under control
people don't realize these trailer
reactions are like a 12 million dollar
budget per video I said invest a lot of
money that I don't have but I lied a lot
of people thinking they're gonna get
paid coming getting [ __ ] serious know
anything it's too later than I care all
my in front of the ear from the camera
now so it was just look like an ass if
you leave okay yeah we ok got me that
well now really want to watch this trail
yeah
don't leave in the middle of it
I be the best in the world
I've got a world someone go
so we go good
whoa what we as a nation fell on
I want to see this country so again with
you yeah me winning me out America
winning
Wow dude this is more than just some
Kuzma
it's about what the metal represents the
virtues it requires to attaining Jesus
that title is very deceiving yeah I
don't even get why it's called that
that looks great oh my god I love a good
drama like that it's like an interesting
intense drama about wrestling yeah yeah
they've taken like a seemingly like
entertaining sort of sport and going
hardcore
yeah really going through the
psychological torment that someone must
go through in order to succeed in that
or something that's crazy that's solely
good
it really does wicked you're really up
to date with your slang far out
yeah there you go
yeah no I the makeup on Steve Carell
kind of blew my mind too I was like I
don't know who he's supposed to be but
still it looks pretty good Mark Ruffalo
has makeup too going on did he look look
like you'd like put on weight or
something you think ah maybe cuz I just
saw him in baking again which opened
like a couple weeks ago he's like old
slim yeah well I don't know I don't know
but I'll look it up for you and call you
she won't make it
I wanna know cuz I know you're too lazy
to look it up yourself so I'll call you
with the information but yeah that does
look great I love like good dramas like
that like there's nothing more moving
than a good drama like people here they
think it's gonna be like weep fest or
something but no it's like those are the
real movies that really get your
emotions and I love a good film like
that that looks like it'll do that so
I'm the director of Moneyball in Capote
come on man
it's gonna be fantastic and Steve Carell
he can do drew if there's any comedian
that I think a new drama well I'd
imagine Steve Carell because he has a
very like straight face dry sense of
humor where his humor is based off
realism a lot of the time have you seen
him in dramas before a little miss
sunshine and dad in real life yes I dan
in real life he was good in that really
and then I did another one that was like
a dramedy but what just really strikes
me about this that seems so interesting
is just how serious the story seems like
you know I've never seen a wrestling
nothing like a wrestling high school
college story I I couldn't tell damn it
Adele well thank you guys to let me know
about that trailer why don't you do this
if you want to click on this button up
here to subscribe and Adele has her own
channel roll credits come say hello say
hello comes a catchphrase or something
yes yeah I just decided you created a
catchphrase for yourself on the spot
yeah yeah mine is let me get straight to
the point here I when I said that I was
like that's gonna be my catchphrase or
click on this but I'm a my dick to
subscribe that's my favorite yeah
can I try it yeah go ahead okay click
the dick to subscribe I should click on
this button by my dick mrs. Crick um
this button by my dick to subscribe dick
my dick to subscribe sorry my apologies
is we're gonna do some shout outs Adele
shout out shout outs Mike now listen I
was going to ask for a shout out but you
look a bit rapey in this review what
does that even mean what why did I I
should have read this free read that
John up before you shouted that out not
sure I want a rapist out out for crying
out loud you look like ron jeremy stunt
double for the toxic avenger for citizen
Toxie anyways by the way I only give you
[ __ ] because I care and enjoy your humor
insert dick joke here ok Mike is it a
dry sense of humor
I like it yeah nothing like a good a
rape joke which this is I'm very
uncomfortable with rape jokes I don't
think they're ever funny funny no they
aren't but that was good job Mike you
got a laugh out of us and a no-quit
laugh I had an offer laugh - Alex Maroof
oh hey can I please get a shout out yes
you said you said yeah well your hand
almost touch my face that was amazing
that was the closest that's the most
intimacy I've had in a while thank you I
feel very special
oh good thing I shaved anyway Alex yeah
thank you for asking for the shoutout
cuz that gotta happen just now oh you
the man
MC King may I + have a shout-out you are
the man maybe not
JK you're a [ __ ] why would you
say you're the man and then go maybe not
what the hell's up with that MC cake TT
dick who does that to people
MC King he does that to people yeah what
a [ __ ] so um yeah is uh MC you're dated
MC before like a DJ host no your
boyfriend's not black right
yeah no you're dated a black guy Wow you
were any other very person very
disappointing answer one of these is led
to it yes anyway I'm assuming you're
black MC King just because her name is
MC King or it could be Mick King oh oh
it's like it's like the Burger King and
Ronald McDonald but had Mickey